Alabama curent and former players have
made over $1.9 billion under Nick Sabin
if you include the most recent draft
class that's well over $2 billion how do
you feel coach saving gets everybody
prepared for the NFL he really teaches
us dynamics of Excellence never being
complacent having a strong work ethic
day in and day out and I just believe
that propelled us to exceed certain
levels obviously we had three star four
star five star recruits but for him to
be able to ex that Legacy and establish
that Excellence is just a testament to
him and what he does for the players
around him it's just going to keep on
building it's never going to go away but
as long as he want to be in college
during those experiences I learned a lot
from him